So how many overall
comparisons was that?
Well, let's try to find a pattern here.
It looks like at each step,
we did one less comparison than
the array we were building.
So when we were building an array of
seven, we only did six comparisons.
When we're building an array of three,
we did two comparisons, an array of two,
one comparison, and an array of four,
we did three comparisons.
I'm going to go ahead and
call the length of each array m just
to make it a little easier for me.
So if m is the size of
the array that we're building,
the number of comparisons is always
going to be one less than that.
It's going to be hard to get
an exact number of comparisons here.
However, we have a good friend that
we can count on, approximation.
Since we know that every iteration
just cycles through the same
seven elements again and again,
we know that the size of our arrays,
or m, are always going to
add up to seven at the end.
So again,
here we have an array of seven.
Here we have an array of four and an
array of three, which adds up to seven.
And here, one, two, two,
and two adds up to seven.
Since we're just doing divide and
conquer, splitting up the array at each
step, we can say that approximately
we're going to do seven
comparisons at each step.
Again, seven is an upper bound.
We're never going to do more
than seven comparisons, but
at many steps we get close to seven.
So to get the run time of a sorting
algorithm, you can normally multiply
the number of overall iterations by the
number of comparisons at each iteration.
In bubble sort,
we were doing n comparisons and n steps.
We just proved that we're doing at
most n comparisons at every step.
But how many steps overall are we doing?
Okay, so to sort an array of seven,
we had to do three steps,
one, two, and three.
Also I should note some of
the sub-processes that happened here.
In order to sort this array of two,
we only had to do one step.
When we were sorting
an array of three or
an array of four,
we needed to do two steps.
We can use a nice table to
keep track of all of that.
Again, so when our array size was seven,
we had to do three different steps.
When our array was three or four
numbers large, we had to do two steps.
When our array was two large,
we had to do one step.
And if we just had one element, we don't
need to do any comparisons, so no steps.
I'm going to go ahead and fill in a few
numbers here just for the sake of time.
You can assume that I did these
calculations on my own and
I encourage you to do them as well.
Okay, so this might look
a little bit familiar to you.
Remember in binary search when
we had a similar table and
the number of iterations
incremented at every power of two.
Well, we actually have
something pretty similar here.
Instead of incrementing
at the powers of two,
this time we're incrementing
one after every power of two.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
So, in the binary search video,
I proved why the number of
iterations would be equal to log(n).
So if you need a refresher,
you can go back there.
Again, this time is a little
different because it increments
after the power of two instead
of at the power of two.
Yet again, we're kind of
relying on approximation here.
We don't exactly care
where the change happens
as long as we capture the interval
at which the change is happening.
So in summary, we're doing roughly
n comparisons for log(n) steps.
That makes an overall
complexity of nlog(n).
This is definitely better than the n
squared we got in bubble sort.
In bubble sort, we had n times n or
n squared as our efficiency.
log(n) is generally going to
be less than n, but
it's definitely never going
to be greater than n.
So we can say that the efficiency
of merge sort is better than
the efficiency of bubble sort.
However, the space efficiency of merge
sort is actually worse than bubble sort.
In bubble sort,
we were sorting in place, so
we didn't need to use any extra arrays.
Here we frequently copied
our values into new arrays.
You can say that the auxiliary space or
the extra space we used was linear.
This complexity assumes that we got rid
of arrays after we were done using them.
At each step, we were copying
values into new arrays, so
we needed new arrays at some point.
However, we could say that we were
getting rid of the old ones whenever we
were done.
So we're not using a ton
of new arrays every time.
We really only need two different arrays
at every step, the array that our
numbers were in and the new array
that we're copying the values into.